For humans, monitoring vital signs is usually
just a matter of wearing a small device on
the tip of your finger
or a quick listen with the stethoscope
and you’re good to go.
But for small animals, such as mice or birds,
checking vitals can involve shaving hair,
plucking feathers, sometimes even surgery
and anesthesia.
These procedures can be stressful for the
animals
and you don’t always get the best readings.
Now researchers have developed a non-invasive device
that can monitor the vital signs of small animals
using either a tiny antennae or RFID tags —
like those used in stores to track inventory.
The device uses “near-field coherent sensing”
to read pulse, heart rate, and breathing—
all without touching the animal.
“Near-field” refers to the electromagnetic field
directly around an RFID antenna -
this allows readings up to 7 cm away from the antenna.
In this setup, the small antenna directs waves
of electromagnetic energy towards the animal
and towards a receiver.
Once these waves reflect off the body,
the receiver can analyze the differences
between them.
Changes in phase are used to detect motion—
like breathing or pulse.
The heartbeat is signaled by changes in amplitude.
To get blood pressure, the timing
of the heartbeat and pulse are compared.
The researchers tested the method on a rat,
and found the RFID antenna was just as accurate
at monitoring heartbeat and breathing rate
as an electrocardiogram.
Scientists successfully tested the device
with parakeets, hamsters and betta fish—
yes, even underwater!
This touchless-sensing technology
was originally developed for reading
vital signs in humans.
Imagine a hospital where each patient
has their own unique RFID tag, sewn directly into
their hospital gown, with a central reader
that can monitor up to 200 people at once.
The tags could even be used to detect other
internal motions in the body
such as bowel or eye movement.
Researchers believe in the future
this new technology will allow scientists to track
vital signs in a wide variety of laboratory animals
and vets to check on exotic pets
much more humanely,
so your hamster won’t have to stress over getting
a haircut just to get a reading of his heart rate.